actually I have to mention for you that
this is this is Scandinavian television
is Norwegian Swedish television and I
mentioned that because in one of your
books you write about Norwegian
television and you're right it's like
the sensation of a coma without the
worry and inconvenience great shape
myself to the Scandinavian today yes
this was this this goes back to this
must have been the late 80s when I came
I was sent by grantor magazine to go to
hammer fest you know way to to see the
Northern Lights
I feel terrible saying it's because the
people at hammer fest would just love
these people in the world they're really
so nice to me but it is the worst place
in the world it's been two weeks the way
the father and I used to sit on the at
the in the bedroom watching Norwegian
television as I recalled it was just one
channel maybe there were two but I'd be
sitting watching like The Flintstones in
Norwegian I was so bored that I I was
just sitting there watching television
just to try to kill time there was it
was a documentary about people in
Lapland herding reindeer and they and
and it just was them just going this way
across the screen just just chasing his
reindeer moving this Ranger across the
screen and I watched her for as long as
I could and then I went downstairs to
the bar and and I had my two beers and
my dinner and I came back upstairs like
an hour and a half two hours later I put
the TV on again and all the Ranger were
going this way
sir
based on that I concluded that Norwegian
televisions not perhaps the most
stimulating well I I'm happy to give you
this opportunity to make it better I'm
so glad you're here and we were talking
about the defining moments here defining
moments in our careers and they finding
travels and I think you're first I mean
you're you're you're born and raised in
Iowa I'm but then you started to travel
and your first travel abroad was also
very defining for you I went to England
and entirely by chance kind of long
story but I by chance I ended up getting
a job in a psychiatric hospital just
outside London and I took this job
intending to stay for three or four
months and just as a paid holiday and
during that time I met my wife who was a
student nurse there my future wife was a
student nurse there and so I ended up
falling for her and falling for England
at simultaneously and that was 40 years
ago and I'm still with both of them do
you feel like you're English now no I
don't never feel like I'm English um but
but I'm you know I it's a really strange
position to be I mean being a foreigner
is a delightful thing to be it's it's
you know it's a very privileged position
because I can you know when things are
going well I can I can kind of join in
the celebrations I know what's going on
I am you know pretty much an intimate
part of the culture but like when they
get England gets knocked out of the
World Cup or something I can stand back
and say these poor people they can't
play so you can kind of choose which
parts you take partnered so yeah I do
feel because I've been there for so long
my kids were all born then my kids are
all you know definitively British and my
wife is English and all of that and
almost all my really long-term friends
are British um I do feel very much at
home there but at the same time I will
you know I will never stop beating him
an American is what I am it's one of my
defining qualities but for you as an
American would he sound like it like a
British man or um I can't really tell
where he's from to be honest but I
talked him before and found out that he
was also a Red Sox fan see cool but is
it how did he do with the language I
mean it's it's
we speak well there is and even now I
mean even though I've been married for
40 years since the just British woman I
still find even now you know I get
confused about things so we have
misunderstandings there was a truce to
straight happen not that long ago where
we actually couldn't understand each
other we would my wife was talking about
I thought she was talking about the
fabric cocky you know the the fabric
she was actually talking about the car
keys and things like that happened from
time to time where I actually don't
understand my own wife and that's that
is that is quite weird it's very common
did you ever have a language coach when
you do I mean when you do yes it seemed
like foreign language like English
because you have to work with accidents
waves from the south no I can't do that
no hardly bothered when we have the
collywobbles thank Joyce but the worst
thing I could do the same ones and and
it was great expectations they asked me
and I said oh I can't do that you know
I'm Swedish I can't do that
yes I don't know that and it has to be
from 1840 something from Kent it's a
very hard accent so I called my language
coach as Mary sees amazing it's a game
and they're all the lines and and I send
them of tape because I felt like they
will not accept this and a Senate tape
and we still remember the first line was
me and used two ladders not do together
long I and that was six years ago or
something I still know they see that
tape on that Swede every Christmas party
still embarrassed about that
what you what you actually did to become
British was that you have you took this
test right because today you're a
British citizen I am I am the events